[Musique]
c'est moi nous avons été bons du coup je
vais très sympa tout ce que leur faire
une petite présentation ge et expliquer
comment tu vas fort et avis et comme je
suis un mec encore plus sympa que je
vais faire une présentation pour te dire
comment tu peux essayer de s'en sortir
quand même ce que je vais expliquer
c'est quand même assez basique c'est à
peu près du niveau faut pas avoir trop
d'alcool mais c'est pas grave parce
qu'on fait pas trop de cours de
prévention en santé mentale donc je me
suis dit que ce serait bien que je le
fasse donc imagine tu vas voir tombe
site et il va prendre en compte plein de
choses pour analyser ta vie enfin s'il
est compétent bon du coup la seule chose
normale en a entendu parler la santé par
exemple à des magazines pourtant parler
des émotions à des applis et des astuces
dans les magazines féminins pour arriver
à la gérer donc quand je nage le courant
va prendre un truc dont on nous parle
pas et c'est un peu con c'est en fait
tes pensées ta façon de voir le monde
comment tu vois les autres comment tu
veux toi toi et vous comment tu vois le
monde et c'est quoi en fait parce que
cette façon dans le monde à l'aide
influence sur l'art de choc de tout être
déterminée par cette façon dans les
choux
par exemple des émotions
tu vois que les différences entre dire
j'ai fermé mon exam suis foutu avis et
de dire je ferai mon exam je vais enfin
pouvoir envoyer chine et pointent leur
dire que c'est pas de bol je voulais
voilà c'est pas du tout la même fait les
mêmes au niveau de la santé si tu as
déjà été une feuille n'ya que tu vois
que 4h du mat qui tourne dans la tête
c'est un forcément dépensé depuis
tranquillement
donc du coup parmi ses pensées il ya ce
qu'on appelle des croyances limitantes
qui sont les 80 christ aime bien
bousculer ses cours je suis fier mais
voilà donc après dix minutes et de deux
façons la première qu'on connaît bien
c'est sous forme de pensée autour des
precia trice je suis très fier de
l'avoir dit sans avoir fauché et on les
connaît bien parce qu'on en parle
souvent et ça peut arriver
gens très bien par exemple un jour
j'avais un entretien d'embauché de
monsieur m'a regardé comme ça tu puisses
tu es vieux chais passe aveugle je fais
ce qui est moins sérieuses et vous
trouvez un coup et des tu dois te dire
une connerie et alors je sais pas si
j'ai dit une connerie je serai jamais
par contre ce que je sais c'est qu'après
j'ai du coup j'ai fait attention à ce
que j'ai dit j'ai fait attention à sa
tête
j'ai perdu mes moyens ça a été
catastrophique ouais je vais me liée à
la fin de l'entretien
donc j'ai pas été pris ce qui me paraît
logique mais du coup ce que j'ai appris
c'est au lieu de préparer les questions
réponses genre trois qualités trois
défauts et p j'ai appris à gérer des
conneries qu'elle aime envoyer mon
cerveau au moment où je suis enfin de
parler aux gens et ça ça m'a vachement
plus céder que juste le bal sur internet
et regarder les questions m la deuxième
chose en quoi ça peut te limitée et là
c'est un peu plus dur à accepter parce
qu'à la nécessité de remettre en
question beaucoup de choses c'est toutes
les réactions de colère que tu ferais à
voir et de comment tu considères que le
monde il doit être et ça ça va être
limité parce que finalement toutes les
croyances
elles limitent sa flexibilité mentale je
prends un exemple horrible
c'est l'exemple de il faut pas tuer on
est tous d'accord il faut pas constitué
mon seul fils coûte parce que moi si un
mec qu'il m'attaque avec un couteau
je préfère que le plant est plutôt
qu'une plante et puis quand même des
métiers on apprend aux gens at il
d'autres personnes donc même dingue qui
ont leur logique finalement sont
discutables et donc la remettre en place
remettre en s'aidant de croyance à
devenir donc remettre en question ses
croyances c'est compliqué parce que ça
nécessite de remettre en question
beaucoup de choses il ya notre ego et
notre façon dont les choses et ça ça
fait quand même assez mal aux au corps
et à l'esprit parce que ressemble pas
c'est bon du coup comme je suis sympa
coquine dit on va apprendre à quoi faire
pour justement gérer ses croyances et
pour pas que de l'empêchent de venir au
tennis comme tu devrais la livre est une
des premières choses à savoir
je sais qu'en fait il ya un lien
hipercor entre tes émotions étaient
pensées ton cerveau il est cohérent si
par exemple que d'émotions négatives
c'est à dire que ton cerveau interprète
la situation de manière négative alors
des fois c'est pas apparent tu vas pas
comprendre pourquoi le père d'un enfant
il devrait être content on en fait il
est pas content mais il ya toujours une
tolérance et inversement si tu as une
émotion positive c'est conservons évalue
la situation de la mère positive et donc
l'une des premières choses à faire ce
que veut découvrir tes croyances ta
façon de voir le monde et j'essaie juste
de te concentrer sur ce que tu restes en
voilà par exemple est avoir été exempté
tristan mitchell est tu te concentres à
fond dessus étudier la première chose
qui te passe par l'esprit et des fois il
ya une croyance qui va sortir
directement par exemple est stressé
avant de faire un concert de guitare et
ton cerveau et yb tu vas te voir et les
gens ne vont pas traîner
voilà mon
pourquoi pourquoi soirée on sait pas
mais des fois ton cerveau va t'en vas y
ait une information et cohérente
genre tu vas neeman il va te dire papier
peint ou alors il va sortir juste un
film par exemple je ferai mon examen et
ça c'est pas une croyance des 80 puisque
c'est un fait mais ça c'est pas grave
qui te sortent des choses incohérentes
parce que l'air je vais t'expliquer le
truc plus important à retenir de la
présentation donc fait bien gaffe c'est
qu'en fait tout ce que tu penses être
vraiment un problème en fait c'est pas
forcément le problème principal est là
j'ai besoin de te montrer de faire la
démonstration avec un exemple où j'étais
particulièrement stupide nous conservons
été stupide donc je rentre chez des
potes je voulais passer une bonne soirée
et là je me sens pas bien donc je fais
ce que je vous ai dit tout à l'heure tu
me concentre sur mon malaise et je dédie
mon cerveau ce qu'ils disent et papier
vous ayez toutes lettres
bon un papier peint sa j'habite chez
personne ça peut pas me tomber dessus
m'asphyxier du moins je crois pas que ce
soit dans le monde déjà et l'image fait
beaucoup rire effectivement je vais pas
pu la faire parce que ça va perturber
tellement bon l'idée c'est que du coup
comment faire avec mon cerveau qui est
incohérent pour découvrir les croyances
qui nous donne finalement cette
sensation d'être mal chez les potes et
bien il ya une technique qui est très
bien qu on appelle ça du scénario
catastrophe ou de la flèche descendante
quatre buts c'est le prévoir le pire du
pire du pire du pire du pire qui peut
arriver pour essayer de trouver vraiment
ce qu'il ya derrière tournée motion par
exemple la dont je dit bon écoute
cerveau des millions mais le papier
peint c'est la tête tu es donc c'est pas
le pire nous avons évité le pire c'est
qu'il est moche quand il gèle papier
peint c'est pas top mais les bleus
populaire des années 70 la république
donc ça on est d'accord mais à l'élite
sexe qui peut pas d'un sensations bon je
dis au pire qu'est ce qu'il ya c'est
quoi le problème puis les moches n'est
pas le problème
et là vous ça vous dit c'est à dire que
les gens quittent accueilli son mauvais
goût et si l'on nous les goûts ça veut
dire qu'ils sont pas intéressants et
s'ils sont intéressants c'est à dire que
t'es plein c'est pendant 82 faire chier
récup et ça par contre c'est une
explication
la personnalité qui pouvait expliquer
mon niveau de malaise et donc on voit
puis finalement dans une situation à la
con ton cerveau il crée plein de
prudential qu'un de croyance derrière
tes émotions qui vont le dire
potentiellement te flinguer l'assuré
parce que si je n'étais pas analysé se
retrouve à la fin je réponds plus les
autres un pas intéressant parce que
j'aurais fait la gueule toute la soirée
en réalité en analysant ça j'ai pu le
passer une bonne soirée et donc en fait
le but des scénarii catastrophes place
et d'essayer de comprendre ce qu'il ya
derrière des émotions et si on extrapole
par exemple quelque chose de plus
professionnelles comme les chèques en
fait n'est pas programmé pour être
sentir les choses en tête un cerveau il
s'en fout l'important c'est de trouver
qu est-ce qui touche quand tu te plantes
est-ce que c'est du coup tu te plantes
et du coup tu vas perdre de l'astien de
toi même est ce que tu as à perdre la
chance d'avoir le bon bout de tes rêves
et donc du coup d'avoir la stimulation
et eric tu veux est ce que tu vas perdre
l'amour de tes profs c'est ça qu'il faut
chercher en fait un besoin fondamental
d'un être humain parce que t'as pas de
casse dans le conte cerveau utilise
l'échec c'est important où la réussite
ce important ou alors l'argent c'est
important en fait via ton cerveau il
s'en fout des chèques par exemple si tu
as déjà eu des nourrissons bon ils sont
environ 2,85
j ai très bien mûri sont donc là c'est
son cerveau était sensible à l'échec
le gosse il irait avoir de ces banques
j'arrête j'arrête de bouger parce que
j'arrive pas à marcher et là on serait
foutu de ministres et serait morte en
châtiment était comme ça donc on s'est
revus il adore les serveurs mais il
apprend comme ça l'état prend tu plantes
en donc échec c'est pas le problème
c'est ce que tu vois d'ailleurs échec
qui la prend si la balle du site est
arrêté au premier service pipe et il
était foutu c'est pareil dans la vie de
manière générale fois que c'était
laisser les rares et donc pour pouvoir
accepter les c'est l'erreur c'est déjà
découvert pourquoi c'est gratuit toi et
donc ça c'est la première chose c'est
pas s'occuper du problème de surface
mais vraiment ce qu'il ya derrière de
très important dans toi et sept
exercices répétés des centaines
tu arrives à te connaître
progressivement par exemple moi j'ai dix
mille émotions différentes l'eau finale
dans ce message
comme souvent ce sont deux ou trois
trucs qu'il franchit dans la vie donc
c'est important de faire et tu peut même
le faire pour comprendre les autres là
plein de gens qui ont lu une copine moi
un copain qui avait 15 ou 16 de moyenne
et qui se pressaient toujours avant ils
contrôlent avec les émotions
je ne sais pas s'il est réussi et la
première la chance et tu as envie de la
claquer à personne parce que elle va
avoir de meilleures notes de coeur en
fête
voilà tu le sais mais comme tu es gentil
talent et lui dire non mais tu peux y
arriver à chaque instant belle et tu
comprenais pas pourquoi parce que tu as
été gentil vient en fait c'est parce que
l'échec elle s'en fout par exemple
qu'elle voulait c'est l'amour de ses
proches aidants comme tu lui dis tu vas
réussir s 40 ans et tu vois je crois en
toi
donc si tu te plantes il va être encore
plus déçu et là on lui faut encore plus
de pression tu peut même utiliser cet
ennemi pour te défendre avec les gens
qui me font chier
par exemple quand collègues il fait
chier parce que t'as pas envie que ce
dossier là tu veux dire qu'est ce qu'on
en a à au pied le stade
franchement wendy on s'en fout et la vie
va te dire mais c'est à dire que tu me
respectes pas tu vois bien moi je le
vois pas en fait parce que n'a pas parce
qu'en fait c'est en cours ça des
cerveaux ici sont programmés pour faire
des liens là où il y en a pas et 3 des
choses qui n'existent pas ou qui sont
pas réalistes mais c'est pas grave parce
qu'on est tous pareils et on peut tous
apprendre à prendre du recul et
finalement voir que tous nos
comportements où les émotions sont
faites à cause d'une croyance qui vont
unité nous bloquer par mon comportement
donc le pôle est effectivement après on
peut discuter avec lui de ce que c'est
le respect sinon kader keita donc là
c'est pas excessivement grave
donc effectivement c'est tout con tu
peux essayer cette technique ça marche
bien ça n'a pas tout
fillon d'état vie mais au moins si ça
peut juste qui permettra un petit
décalage pour comprendre que derrière
ces comportements ça peut être pas mal
ça peut éviter pas mal de remettre par
la suite bon du coup après la question
imagine en effet sa tête a trouvé et
croyances par exemple si je me pose
c'est une foire les gens vont pas
d'aimer et donc du commentateur du 3 et
du coup tu vas pas faire qu'en est-il
des guitares bon une fois que tu as fait
ça mais il ya plusieurs techniques qui
peuvent aider alors j'ai lâché ou pas le
temps de me fait dire des techniques
pour t'aider remettre en cause les
croyances mais c'est pas grave si tu
veux j'ai plein de livres et j'ai
quelques livres que je te filet ils
permettront d'y arriver correctement et
du coup mais juste d'introduire les dom
m
le technique et comme sa cianas qui
t'intéresse pas qui pourrait le vérifier
sur internet si c'est donc en gros il ya
trois domaines
j'ai enlevé le médicament parce que
c'est pas mon cas mais méconnaissables
et puis que médicalement souvent luxe et
c'est vraiment une bêtise quand tu es
vraiment mal donc le premier domaine en
fait c'est les techniques qu'on appelle
cognitives aidé à me bull serait
d'utiliser son intellect ton
intelligence pour modifier des croyances
same as ça paraît logique effectivement
dit comme ça et le but c'est absolument
pas de penser positif le but se pensait
faire juste parce que la taxe est
positive on a remarqué se forcer à
penser positif ça marche surtout quand
on n'a pas de problème dès que les gens
mon problème des croyances top ça marche
plus donc en fait vous dit que c'est dû
faire un petit décalage sur ce que tu
ressens
enfin tu t'es fois et pour l'entreprise
a déposé le bilan était très nette
impression d'être un gros loser
ok bon but de faire ce décalage par jean
de se dire en ce moment chez brother et
entre chez un gros loser et inspirant
chaud
l'usr iliad inquiets de l'avenir et
l'autre qui en a pas et c'est la
différence entre quelqu'un qu'il est
triste mais quelqu'un qui va finir
dépressif hongrie finalement juste un
petit décalage de point de vue pourquoi
chercher à la mercy vouloir être très
positif mais c'est juste assumer ce
qu'on a et jusqu'à vendredi les calèches
pour voir ce qui se passe
bon ça c'est le premier type de
technique après talent et ses
comportements graves aulas le but c'est
de dire en gros
va te faire ça ton cerveau et de
faire l'inversé de ce qui te dit de
terre par exemple tu as peur d'aller
chanter par des gens sans cerveaux
diktats ridicules ils vont se moquer de
toi là tu dis j'en avais mcafee et tu
vois ce qui se passe alors évidemment si
tu les veux tu te plains tu vaut mieux
pas y aller mais c'est pour ça qu'un tel
ou tel programme
elles se font avec des règles pour
commence assure que la personne ait un
retour positif de son expérience et
enfin les plus récentes
ils sont super intéressante pro
celebrity émotionnel ou luxmètre
d'utiliser des images des métaphores
pour donner une saveur différente à ce
que tu es entrain dur dans les actions
prend l'échec comme je vous ai dit on
n'est pas sensible et l'échec à la base
donc à un moment donné il ya quelqu'un
qui t'a appris le toi tu as pris par
terrible c'était important de réussir et
que ta performance était importante
tu peux dire c'est quoi est ce que c'est
moi qui me suis lancé un défi
est-ce que c'est mes parents qui m'ont
éduqué l'échec ou la réussite
est-ce que c'est l'épreuve qui l'ont
fait et après tu peux réaliser par
exemple des petits dialogues entre toi
d'avant qui a cru que l'échec ce timbre
grave et toi de maintenant qu'il n'a
plus rien et comme ça ça permet
de prendre du recul ce que tu ressens
pas ce que tu fais un dialogue avec toi
même alors il ya de l'intégrer dans ja
bell sont pas mal
un problème notamment le problème de
maltraitance et observa chemin donc si
on résume tout toutes les émotions ont
finalement et les comportements on va
être dicté par des croyances
potentiellement limitantes parce
qu'elles vont bloquer ta créativité vos
boules keita flexibilité et ça tu peux
pas de changer on est tous stupides
enfants nous mais c'est pas grave on
peut très bien l'assumer
minus est parti deux fois les premières
db comme avec l'histoire du papier peint
parce que oui c'est débile de penser que
des gens qui ont un haut niveau sont
inintéressants d'ailleurs ils peuvent
être intéressants parce qu'ils sont
mauvais goût justement voilà mais du
coup tu peux pas rester là dessus il
faut quand même essayer de comprendre et
moi j'étais donnez moi une technique que
tous nous on peut l'utiliser dans sa vie
de tous les jours pour essayer de
comprendre soi-même les autres pour
ensuite trouver la meilleure stratégie
parce que si tu essaies trouver une
stratégie avant de comprendre le
problème
la cci c'est à dire ça marche pas voilà
faut comprendre le problème avant donc
ni par le petit enfant antoine qui
pleure parce qu'ils existent et tu peux
pas le changer
par contre tu peux effectivement
développé des gens qui sont là pour
limiter l'écouté et aller de l'avant et
ça ça peut effectivement servir je
m'arrêter là parce que rien si intime
agents fêtes vous donne envie de
raconter trois mille trucs différents
je pense qu'il faut que je dise une
juste représentation de 15 minutes
voilà
[Musique]